I'm pretty cynical by nature, but the last
two months have seen how I don't know if it's
30 percent or 40 percent of the country has
been dealing with Corona virus.
It's really made me lose like even more faith
in humanity than I had already lost, at least
American humanity.
We already did a story on the bonus show about
how one third of the country believes coronavirus
was created deliberately rather than evolving
as viruses do.
And this is already very, very bad.
And we increasingly now have the sort of liberty
crowd, the people that fetishize a myopic
version of what freedom is starting to protest,
that we must open the country.
Many of them have even been gathering in large
groups in order to demand that the country
be opened.
And one such rally happened in Michigan yesterday
and other one happening, I believe, today
in Kentucky.
Possibly.
But all of today's videos are from yesterday
in Michigan.
And Michigan is having a real problem with
coronavirus.
Michigan is in the top eight states in cases
per capita.
Michigan is in the top four states in deaths
And they're not doing that much testing.
They're only testing 30 second per capita
in the United States.
And of course, many states simply do not have
tests.
It's beyond many states to be able to do more
testing.
The point is high death per capita, low testing
per capita in Michigan.
People have to stay the hell home.
So here are protesters gathering in huge groups.
Now you're going to hear if you're not watching.
I'll tell you some of what you're going to
hear.
You're going to hear screams of lock her up,
referring to Michigan Governor Gretchen Whitmer.
You're going to hear screams of recall wittmer.
You'll hear USA USA chants.
And, of course, what you will see if you're
watching as a huge crowd of people when we're
trying to fight a virus that spreads through
droplet contagion.
Take a look.
Instead, I hear in American.
I hear interviews with two people, one guy
crying about being unable to get lawn fertilizer
and a woman complaining about not being able
to dye her gray roots, bending down to show
how the roots are tragically coming in.
I can't go between those houses.
You can't buy paint.
You can't buy a law.
You can't buy lawn fertilizer, grass seed
or what?
Come on.
All statewide.
Really?
You know, it's time for our state to be opened
up.
We're tired of not being able to buy the things
that we need.
Go to the hairdressers, get her hair done.
So, I mean, listen, the guy who's crying about
fertilizer, if you're that desperate for some
manure, just watch trumps daily press briefings
and you'll get more more than your daily allotment.
But this is really, really crazy.
First of all, you know the woman with the
hair dye.
Twenty five hundred people died in the United
States on Wednesday this week from Corona
virus.
This is the most in one day in any country
since the start of the pandemic.
She's complaining about dyeing her hair is
the reason that the state needs to reopen.
It also seems like these people aren't just
either aware or telling the truth about what's
going on in their states because the guy lot
of crying about manure.
I looked into it.
Hardware stores are open in Michigan.
They will give you fertilizer.
They'll even bring you have to call ahead
and give you a credit card.
They'll bring it out to your car.
You can order it from Amazon.
Amazon shipments are taking quite a while
right now, but it'll get to you.
The idea that, you know, he's crying because
he can't get fertilizer, you can get fertilizer.
I don't know if he has access to the Internet.
So this is the epitome of the ugly side of
America.
And it is not lost on me that both of these
individuals appear to be in higher risk groups
based on their age groups that should really
be staying home right now, completely entitled,
completely lacking in understanding of basic
science.
And they are indignant at others looking to
help people and stay home.
They're also wrong on the facts and confused
about the world around them.
So it's sort of like a perfect trumpet.
And I've said it before.
I don't want anyone to die from this, but
if they were only putting themselves at risk,
I would say, okay, you know what?
If people want to risk death and they're not
endangering anyone else, let them do it.
Like, how much are we going to fight them
if they're only putting themselves at risk?
Let it rip, so to speak.
But they do put others at risk.
People who do understand what's going on.
Recognize that those people are putting at
risk people in a position where they may get
the virus and die.
Their actions don't only affect themselves,
they affect everybody around them.
So we have to act collectively here to keep
people safe.
They will never change their minds until they
end their loved ones get sick.
And by then it's going to be told too late,
they'll have spread it already.
Most will still vote for Trump in November
regardless.
Remember when Trump said his Vietnam was avoiding
S.A.T.'s during like the 1980s or something
like that?
For these people not dying their hair as a
sacrifice, as tens of thousands of people
are dying and health care workers are in war
like conditions every day.
They are considering this a big battle for
them.
And I get it.
You know, I am sick of being home.
I want to see people.
I want to go out.
I just want to sit in a restaurant for a couple
of hours.
I totally understand it.
But this is bigger than any one of us, and
particularly for a lot of these folks who
are religious and tend to subscribe to the
idea that there's something bigger than them
that connects to their actions every single
day.
How is it that they don't get that same idea
applies in a real way to what we're doing
here and trying to stop the spread?
It's disheartening.
It's concerning.
It's disappointing.
And unfortunately, they're not only putting
themselves at risk.
If it were only risking their own lives at
certain point, I would say go ahead and do
it.
But that's
not
the situation.